Next, we're going to learn about the statement syntax
in Jinja. The statement syntax is very simple, it just
looks like this. This is squiggle percent, and then
you have your statement, and then you have a close
squiggle percent. And then you'll often have an ending
statement, which is surrounded by squiggles of course, and in
the middle you have your output. For example, an if
statement might look something like this. So I'll say if
name equals, equals Steve, this is just a Python syntax
for an if statement. Notice there's no colon at the
end. Will print hello Steve. Else will print, who are
you? This whole thing is followed by the end statement
block. Which in this case just says end if. Now
this whole thing is followed by the end statement block,
which in this case just says end if. In Jinja
we have to tell it when the if statement is over.
So what this will do when this is run, if
the variable name Steve or if the variable named name
equals Steve, it'll say, hello Steve! Else, it will say
who are you? And this ends it. Let's go ahead and
see this in practice. Okay, I'm going to get the
variable n from the request and n will be a
number, and we're going to change this to be n
equals n. Then we're going to go into our template and we're
going to change this. We're just going to work on the same
template here if you don't mind. We're going to change this to
use a basic if statement. So if n equals one, say n equals
one, else say n does not equal one.